[Music]
the show wrapped the the finale
obviously is going to be uh next week uh
but uh but the show has been done for
you know about a month now yes sir and
it's all this yes sir stuff
we've been friends for a long time have
we though
i like to think so old pal you are don't
but
what have you been up to since the show
wrapped you've had a lot of time on your
hands what are you doing i'm just
sitting at home trying to not spend
money
really
you've always you've always been a
frugal fellow i think that's fair to say
smart with finances is a nice
spoon that's sort of the definition of
frugal yeah so
cheapskate i say yeah sorry
but it's true you're you know you're one
of those guys that shows up here at the
show and we've known each other for
years and then you know you take a few
donuts and put them in your pocket on
the way out
they're not they might not be for me
yeah um can what are you feeding other
people with doughnuts um against their
okay so
so weird so
since the show wrapped you're you said
you're hanging around that house what
are you doing home i'm just curious well
i do really and truly but i've been
enjoying the weather here in southern
california because it is freezing in new
york
um and i have a beautiful place to stay
out here but uh i've been getting crows
in my backyard
crows the bird crows yeah i know
i didn't think it was the native
american tribe
i assumed
i just okay so crows have been showing
up in your backyard and i mean god bless
i love animals and stuff but they're
terrifying and they bring garbage up
into my backyard and i don't like it
they bring garbage from other places and
drop it in your backyard they do they do
like eggshells and food wrappers and
chicken bones and a dog toy they brought
a dog toy
and they're like the big crows not like
cute little disney right right just sort
of the big the rats of the sky if you
will i never said that all right well
you're gonna get letters for that
comment jack mcbrayer crows are the rats
of the sky
that's what you said but now this might
get me in a little bit of trouble i
borrowed my friend's bb gun what
hear me out
to scare them and not hurt them and so
here i am sitting on my back porch in my
pajamas sitting there with my bb gun
come on crows
and i shoot at them
do you try and hit them no i try to hit
the like the trees that they're sitting
on or my fence that they're sitting on
shoot the gun out of their hand yeah
go ahead but wait a minute
you've always for years if i've made any
joke about you being hill folk or
hillbilly or anything like that you get
all mad at me now you're sitting in your
backyard in your underwear
with a gun waiting on some crows to come
make up some crow stew
are you not
there's no such thing as crow stew
wikipedia it
i see that i'm right
you are such a likable chap i bet you're
going to get all kinds of offers i don't
worry about you at all i think you're
going to get i think you're going to
work constantly at a restaurant
but a very good restaurant
and i can't wait to sit at your table
and be a real jerk